foreign
[Music]
they emerged out of a group of Youth who
defend the city essentially from Israeli
incursions and decided to create a more
formal group that would defend the city
which is where the group name and
organizational structure sort of emerged
foreign
[Music]
to understand the perspective of
Palestinian youth in the West Bank you
have to look at a situation where
there's 800 000 settlers who are
illegally occupying a great percentage
of the land there you have constant
daily attacks on Palestinian youth
whether they're Crossing checkpoints
whether they're walking to school or to
work the number of young Palestinians
run over by cars or attacked by settlers
is large so obviously there's going to
be a lot of popularity among youth in
the West Bank when a group says that
they're not going to accept the presence
of these settlers on their land
[Music]
foreign
I think this is a new generation of
resistance we saw this first last May in
May 2021 with the unity uprisings and
sort of a new generation of Palestinians
Who Rose up in the streets and who
reject essentially the path of
normalization that began with the Oslo
Accords they are rather uncompromising
and steadfast in what they're pursuing
[Music]